ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเองสวัสดีค่ะครูต้อมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนขอบคุณครับก็ต้อง
แสร้งบายดีไหมคะ
สบายดี
กันแรงดีครูต้อมราคาสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะ
แข็งแรงสดใสดีมากนะคะวันนี้ครูต้อมกับกู
เองทั้งแรง
กูตั้งแต่ครูเอกขอ Share  screen นิดนึง
นะคะ
สักครู่นะคะ
สักครู่นึงอ่ะคุยทำอะไรอยู่กูต้องอ๊อดนึง
แป๊บนึงแป๊บแต่ว่ารอนิดหน่อยนะคะอ้ามา
แล้วว
จะ
เอาโอเค
สักครู่ต้องทำครูใหญ่ๆด้วยค่ะเดี๋ยวครู
ตัวเล็กๆนักเรียนจะมองไม่เห็นครู
กูตั้มคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะคุณเอ๋วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 5 ค่ะวันที่ห้า
เดือนอะไรคะเงินมิ.ย.ค่ะเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพศ.อะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
2565 นะคะบีขอศ.อะไรคะมีข้อสอปี
2022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
8:00 น 20 นาทีค่ะ
กรรมรัก
2  7:20 นนะคะหนูต้องกับครูเอ๋ก็จะพูด
พูดจนถึง
20:00 น 50 น -  10 นะคะโอเคค่ะโอเคค่ะ
วันนี้เนี่ยกูต้องคู๋อยากจะมาคุยหนาคุย
กับครูต้อมนะคะเที่ยวกับคนไทยคิดอะไรนะคะ
คิดคนไทยเราเนี่ยนักเรียนวันนี้อ่ะทุกๆ
คุยเคารพก่อนนะคะอ่ะ
อยู่บ้านหรอมาบ้าน
บ้าน
บ้านปกติเราก็ไปทำงานกลับบ้านไปทำงานกลับ
บ้านเสื้อผ้าที่ใส่ใช่มั้ยรัดเสื้อผ้าที่
เราใส่อ่ะคุณต้องเวลาทำงานน่ะกูต้องจะใส่
เสื้อผ้าสีอะไรคะส่วนมากๆเลยอ่ะเสื้อผ้า
กูต้อมส่วนมากกูต้องส่งเสื้อผ้าตัดฝี 1
คู๋พูดแน่ส่วนมากแต่ว่าประมาณ 80%
60 ถึง 80 เปอร์เซ็นต์น่ะสั่ง
เราเรียกว่าส่วนมากส่วนมากครูต้อมใส่
เสื้อสีอะไรคะส่วนมากกูต้องชอบใส่สีเทา
เหมือนๆตัวที่กูต้องใส่อยู่ใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะอันนี้สีเทานะคะแปลว่าถ้านี้ไม่ได้ไป
ทำงานทำงานก็คืออันนี้ออกจากบ้านไปแล้วก็
ไปทำงาน
นะที่ทำงานนี้เป็นขี้ใต้กูต้องจะใส่สีเทา
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยตำรวจไม่ค่อยใส่สีอะไร
ให้ก็ต้องเหลือง
สีเขียว
วันนี้สีเขียวสีเขียวเห็นชอบใส่สีชมพู
กูต้มกูต้องคู๋มีที่ไหนสีชมพู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ฟ้าหรอคะใช่กฎจะหมดสีชมพูสีชมพูเนี่ยอัน
นี้ปากกาสีชมพูโอเคเห็นไหม
ถ้าเห็นนะค่ะ 4 อันนี้กระดาษนะคะนักเรียน
กระดาษสีชมพูนะคะขนาดสีชมพู
แต่คนจริงๆแล้วมีสีที่นี่นะ
เอ้อใช่เขวและสีชมพูมีช่องผู้ต้องไม่มี
ไม่มีค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่
ชอบสีชมพู
เอ้าทำไมกีฬาสีชมพูสวยนะไม่ชอบเวลาเด็กๆ
อ้ะตัว A มีแต่คุณพ่อคุณแม่ซื้อเสื้อสี
ชมพูสีชมพูสีชมพูเกลียดไว้เอาสีชมพู
แดง
2 สีค่ะสีชมพูสีแดงสีชมพูสีแดงเวปเบื่อ
สีชมพูสีแดงตัวเองก็จะมีสีน้ำเงิน
สีฟ้า
สีสีดำแบบนี้เนี้ยสิเมาส์เป็นสีดำเราก็สี
ขาวอ่ะ 40 ชูชิตชูสีขาว
เสื้อผ้ากูเอกในแค่เนี้ยแต่หนุน 4 สีฟ้า
กับสีน้ำเงิน
kuai เหมือนครูต้อมเลยกูต้องก็ไม่ชอบสี
ชมพู
ทำไมหรอกเวลาเด็กๆเราใส่สีชมพูมากๆใช่
มั้ยก็เลยติดๆก็ไม่ชอบสีชมพูไม่ชอบอ่ะใส่
รถขนลูก
ไม่รู้เองอุ้ยรู้สึกตัวเองไม่ใช่ผู้หญิง
ที่ใส่สีชมพู
อะที่นี้ที่ค่ะอันนี้ไปออฟฟิศเราๆเราก็
คือต้องไปเอ๋น่ะก็ใส่เสื้อผ้าตามใจเราเรา
ไม่ชอบสีชมพูก็ไม่ต้องใส่เราไม่ชอบสีแดง
ก็ไม่ต้องใส่นะคะอ่ะมีสีเทาเวอร์ครูเอชอบ
และครูต้อม
แต่ว่าไม่มีเสื้อสีเทาของตัวเอง
มีแต่ของถูกมีแล้วขโมยมาสาย
ดีค่ะกูต้องมีเสื้อสีเทาเยอะมากเลยค่ะใส่
สบายๆเนาะสีเทานะคะที่นี้คนดีเนี่ยไม่ได้
ไปทำงานอย่างเดียวสมมุติวันนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
วันนี้คุณต้อมออกจากบ้านไปที่ทำงานเสร็จ
แล้วต้องไป
โรงแรม
ไปโรงแรมมีผู้ชายกับผู้หญิง
แต่งงาน
แล้วบอกว่าไปงานแต่งงานนะคะแต่งงาน
ใส่สีอะไรกูต้องกับครูเอ๋นะโอเคถ้ามี
ปัญหาใช้ฮะถ้าเรารู้ใส่อะไร
ได้ใส่อะไหล่ไม่ได้
พูดต้อมถ้าไปงานแต่งงานเอาครูต้อมก่อนนะ
เวลาไปงานแต่งงานคุณต้องจะใส่สีอะไรคะ
สีฟ้าค่ะสีฟ้าไปหาก่อนแป๊บ
อันนี้สีฟ้าแบบนี้ล่ะค่ะถ้าสีฟ้าแล้วก็สี
น้ำเงินค่ะกับสีน้ำเงิน
สีน้ำเงิน
หากูต้องจะใส่สีฟ้าสีน้ำเงินนะคะเดี๋ยว
ให้นักเรียนดูงานแต่งงานก่อนเดี๋ยวนั้นก็
What  is แต่งงาน
นี่ค่ะแต่งงานใครอุ้ยอุ้ย
สวยมากจบคุณค่ะแต่ก็ปิดอะไรเอ่ยกูเอ๋ค่ะ
อยู่กับใครไม่รู้นะคะ
แต่งงานกับใครไม่รู้กูเอาหน้าคนนี้ใหญ่ๆ
ก่อนถ้าจะขยาย
น้องก็ต้องก็ปีสองอันเนี่ยเพราะว่า
เฮ้ย
ฮัลโหลเดี๋ยวๆๆ
ฮัลโหล
ก็เปลี่ยนนี้ก็ไม่เห็นหน้าหน่อยค่ะกูเอง
หล่อมากค่ะคือกูอาจจะโดนสามีโกรธไหมคะ
โสดค่ะ
ว่าหล่อค่ะไม่ได้ไม่ได้ค่ะนักเรียนคน
ญี่ปุ่นไม่ได้อ๋อ
คนที่ปุ่นห้ามโชว์น่าจะหลุดไปแล้วไม่เป็น
ไรขออภัยนะคะนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยอ่ะอ่า
โอเคงานแต่งงานอันนี้แต่งงานนะคะงานแต่ง
งานคนที่แต่งงานเจ้าสาวเนี่ยเอ่อถ้าเป็น
ชุดแบบไทยๆสีอะไรก็ได้เนาะหมายถึงนี้คน
นี้อ่ะสีอะไรก็ได้
บางทีก็ไม่ใส่สีขาวนะบางทีก็ใส่สีชมพู
อุ้ย
บางทีคนนี้ก็จะใส่สีชมพู
สีชมพูก็มีบางทีก็ใส่สีแดง
อย่างนี้ต้องถ้า
ชุดแต่งงานสีแดงโอเคไหมครับคุณต้อมโอเค
ค่ะ
เสียอะไร
สีอะไรคุณต้องเหรอคะเวลาคุณต้องแต่งงาน
ใส่สีอะไรคะอ๋อกูต้มไม่แต่งงานค่ะแล้วจบ
กับเรียนๆที่อยู่ด้วย
ละกันเลยค่ะไม่แต่งช่วยคุณต้อง
คิดเหมือนกันไม่ต้องหา
ช่องค่ะสีอะไรแม่ห้อง
ร้านการแล้วก็อยู่ด้วยกันแล้วก็มีลูกเลย
ค่ะ
คุณต้อง
คู่เอกขึ้นคลิปเหมือนครูต้อมป่าไม่ได้ไม่
ได้ไม่ได้นะ
แต่ไม่ได้เอาไงว่าแต่งงานแล้วกันนักเรียน
งานแต่งงานนะคะงานแต่งงานเนี่ยบางงานผู้
ชายน่ะเราเรียกเจ้าบ่าวผู้หญิงเรื่องอะไร
คะ
น้องสาวค่ะเจ้าสาวนะคะเจ้าบ่าวกับเจ้าสาว
ที่นี้เนี่ยเวลาเราไปงานแต่งงานเจ้าสาว
เจ้าสาวเนี่ยมีใส่มีสีขาวสีชมพู
สีแดงสีก็มีละสีส้มเนี่ย
แล้วแต่นักเรียนสีอะไรก็ได้นะคะถ้าเป็น
ชุดแต่งงานที่ที่เขาชอบก็ใส่ได้แต่ผู้ชาย
ก็ใส่สีอะไรก็ได้ยกเว้น
วรรคเว้นสีอะไรคะสีดำ
ใช่มันเจ้าบ่าวที่เมืองไทยไม่มีใครใส่สี
ดำเนาะหมายถึงสูตรตัวนี้ค่ะ 4 ทำเนี่ยไม่
ได้นะคะมากๆจะเป็นสีขาวนะกูต้มเนาะใช่ค่ะ
งานเองไม่ใช่ใส่สีขาวนะคะคือจริงๆครูเอก
คิดกูแอบชอบสีเทาแล้วครูเอกก็ไม่เอาสีดำ
นี่สีดำเนี่ยกูเองไม่เอา
แต่เวดดิ้งสตูดิโอ้เนี่ยอยากให้ใส่อันนี้
กูอีกถ้าเราเปลี่ยนเอาสีเทาแล้วก็เรียบ
ร้อยวันที่มางานแต่งงานก็เอาเสื้อผ้ามากู
M แต่งหน้าอยู่พอเห็น
ไม่มีเวลาเปลี่ยนแล้วทำไมเอาตัวนี้
ไม่เอาสีนี้แล้วมีสีดำมาที่ Wedding
สุริย์เอาออกอันนี้แฟนฉันขอ
แฟชั่นแฟชั่นอันนี้ทุกคนชอบครูเอกกับสามี
ไม่ชอบอ๋อ
น่ารักเพราะว่ากูเองไม่ชอบมีสีดาวมันใน
งานแต่งงานก็เลยอ่ะเออ
อ๋อโหลดนิดหน่อยจะไม่เป็นไรจากนี้บอกไม่
เป็นไรไม่ต้องโกรธสีอะไรก็หล่อไม่เจ้า
บ่าวหรอค่ะ
ทีนี้ถ้าเราไปงานแต่งงาน
อาจไปงานแต่งงานนะคะมี
อดีตคุยเหมือนกันกูไปงานแต่งงานไหนวะ
งานแต่งงานเพื่อน
หาอันนี้ก็เพื่อนคนนี้ใส่ชุดสีอะไรนะคะ
คุณพร้อมมีช่องพุ่มค่า Way ใส่สี
อ๋อค่ะสีฟ้าสีแดงวีนะแต่ว่าชอบใส่แล้วก็
จะมีดอกไม้นกดอกไม้เยอะๆนะคะในงานแต่งงาน
ที่นี้คำถามก็คือคุณจะถามถูกต้องว่าเวลา
ไปงานแต่งงานอ่ะใส่สีดำได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ค่ะ
ผู้ชายผู้หญิงไม่ได้น้อยไม่ได้ค่ะคนไทย
ใส่สีดำไปงานแต่งงานไม่ได้เธอเป็นผู้ชาย
แล้วตอนนี้เราเรียกว่าสู่ดูอื่นลบตรงนี้
ก่อน
ค่ะสูตรตัวเนี๊ยใส่สู่ก็ไม่ใส่เนาะ
ใส่สูตรใหม่สูตร
ก็ได้อัดเสื้อที่อยู่ข้างในต้องเป็นสีสัน
สีชมพูสีชมพูสีฟ้า
เขียวปิด Con ได้หมดค่ะเขาได้ไหมคะดีขาว
ก็ต้องมีเนคไทด์สีชมพูสีอะไรสีแดงแต่ตรง
ขาเอาวะดำขาวไม่ใช่งานแต่งอ่ะเนาะอ่ะ
หน้าก็สีดำแบบผู้หญิงไม่ได้ไม่ได้
สิขาวได้ไหมคะมีข่าวก็ไม่ดีค่ะทำไมอ่ะ
คนไทยคิดว่าสีขาว
คนอื่นนะค่ะใส่แล้วจะสวย
กว่าเจ้าสาวขอเจ้าสาวเจ้าสาวค่ะวันนี้
เจ้าสาว
เจ้าสาวเจ้าสาวเนี่ย
ใส่สีขาวให้ค่ะงั้นเนี่ยถ้าข้าถ้าพี่นี้
เป็นต้อมก็ต้องใส่สีขาว
ต้อมก็จะสวยอาจจะสวยมากกว่าใช่ไหมสวยมาก
กว่าเจ้าสาวไม่ได้
ปิดก้าก็อย่างงั้นใส่สีแดง
ได้ไหมคะสีแดงก็โอเคพอเจ้าสาวใส่สีขาวนะ
คะ
บางงานบางงานให้คุณใส่สีแดงไปไหนก็ชอบมาก
งานอะไรคะคุณเอ๋งานแต่งงานนี่ล่ะค่ะงาน
แต่งงานทุกบ้านควรจะเป็นคนไทยเราก็จีนชัด
คุยไปจีนนะฮะถ้ามีคนใส่สีแดงมางานแต่งงาน
เก๋
นะแม่พ่อจะเห็นแล้วโอ๊ยชอบดีโชคดี
ใส
ใส่สีแดงพ่อแม่ดีใจแต่ครูเอ๋น่ะแดง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ๆๆชอบจ้าชอบใส่มาได้ไม่เป็นไรนะคะ
อ่ะสีม่วงครูต้อมสิวไหมสีม่วงไม่ค่อยดี
เท่าไหร่ค่ะทำไมล่ะ
คนไทยคิดว่าสีม่วงเป็นสี
ผิดหวังเรื่องความรัก
อกหักอกหักเบิร์ด 10 หวังมากร้องให้เธอ
ก็ตัดตาก่อนบางคนนะคะคิดต้องบอกนักเรียน
ก่อนนะคะถ้าบางคนคิดครูเอกก็ได้ยินแม้แต่
คู่เอเด็กๆคู่เอกชอบสีม่วงสีสี
ขาวสีฟ้า
คุณเมื่อก่อนชอบสีม่วงมากๆเราก็เคยไปงาน
แต่งงานแล้วก็คิดใส่สีม่วงแล้วก็มีคนบอก
ว่าหยุด
ห้ามใส่
ทำไม
เขาบอกว่าเวลาถ้าใส่สีม่วงเนี่ยเหมือนกับ
อันนี้ผู้ชาย
จะแฟนแต่งงานกับผู้หญิงและนี้ครูเอก
คู๋นะใส่สีม่วงเนี่ยแต่ว่าครูเอ๋น่ะ
อกหักจากผู้ชาย
มันบอกว่าฉันอกหักจากผู้ชายนะ
จริงหรอตัวเอง
แต่ไม่มีเขียนตัวหนังสือนะว่าหางน่องอ้วน
แต่คนไทยคิดเองใช่มั้ยคุณต้องๆคนไทยคิด
เองค่ะเมื่อก่อนคนไทยคิดมากแบบนี้ตอน
เนี้ยไม่คิดแล้ว
ใช่ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรจริงๆสีม่วงเนี่ย
ใส่ได้แต่ค่ะส่วนมากต้องเป็นคนอายุมาก
กว่าเขาบอกใส่ได้อย่างสมมติว่าพบครูเอ๋
อายุอ่ะ 50 คนแต่งมายุ 30  28  a ใส่สี
ม่วงอันเนี่ยโอเคเขาบอกว่าโชคดีเก่าแต่
บ้านครูอือเด็กๆมีคนบอกห้ามใส่ตัวเองก็
ได้โอเคไม่ใส่ดีกว่า
[เพลง]
จะได้ไม่ใส่ดีกว่าแล้วแล้วครูเอกเคยได้
ยินนะพี่ต้อมไปงานแต่งงานตอนคุยเด็กๆครู
ไปงานแต่งงานอีกอย่างกูเองก็ได้ยินเห็นคน
ใส่สีม่วงมาก็มีคนคุยก็ไม่ใส่สีม่วงมาไม่
ให้น่ะอันนี้อะไรก็มีคนพูดว่าโหลดนิด
หน่อย
ใส่สีแดงไม่เป็นไร
จะเป็นไงโอเคๆเป็นงานใครซีนะคะไทยจีนไม่
ใช่ไทยเส้นจะไทย 100% น่ะเขาบอกม่วงได้
100% เลยนะคะสีม่วง
กับสีดำไม่ได้สีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินอันนี้
ไปงานแต่งงานได้ไหมได้ได้นะคะ
สีน้ำเงินไปงานแต่งงานได้แล้วไปใบงานขน
ทรายได้ไหมคะงานศพ
จริงๆก็ได้นะคะตอนนี้ได้เนาะค่ะและแต่ง
ที่งั้นงานแต่งงานเวลาถ้านักเรียนนะคะได้
ได้การ์ดมาแล้วอ่ะมีเพื่อนคนไทยแต่งงานทำ
ยังไงดีเหมาะก่อนนะมีนักเรียนมาถามครูเอ๋
ไปๆครูเอ๋ใส่เสื้อผ้าสีอะไร
อะไรนะคะฉันมีเพื่อนจะแต่งงานใส่สีอะไรนะ
คะก็ถ้านักเรียนมีชุดชุดกลางเนี่ยแบบนี้
ไปงานแต่งงานได้ไหมกูซ่อมได้นมก็ได้นะคะ
เหมือนชุดไปออฟฟิศเนอะก็ได้ชุดนี้ไปงาน
แต่งงานได้สีดำ
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
โอเคเมื่อกี้งานแต่งงานกูยังพูดไม่จบ
ใส่สร้อยมุกได้ไหมคะ
ก็ได้นะคะโอ๋เอ๋จริงป่าว
อ๋อ
โอเคบางคนได้บางคนไม่ได้ถ้าอ่ะมีทรายอัน
นี้
อย่างนี้โอเคเลยโอเคมากสวยมากงานแต่งงาน
สีแดงสีเขียวสีเหลืองอะไรก็ได้นะคะ
มุกเนี่ยมันคนโอเคกูต้อมโอเค
ครูเอ๋เอ๋
โอเคมาเลยใส่ไส้มุกแล้วมางานแต่งงานเอง
ไม่เป็นไรแบบอันนี้แม่
พ่อพ่อกูเองไม่เป็นไรนะคะอันนี้
พี่สาวพี่ชายครูเอ๋
เนาะพี่ชายคู๋เป็น
เหี๊ยไม่เป็นไรพี่ชายเป็น
น้องครูเอ๋ไม่เป็นไรน้องชายไม่เป็นไรพ่อ
ไม่เป็นไรแม่
แม่ป้า
[เพลง]
แต่
ไม่ชอบ
อาจจะบอกว่าอันนี้ไปงานงานศพเอางั้นงานศพ
ก็คืองานแบบนี้นะคะไปก่อนนะเอาคนใน
ครอบครัวมาไม่เป็นไรเนาะลืมปิดลืมปิดหน้า
ก็ปิดหน้าก่อน
อันไม่ได้
อ่านไว้อา
ทำไมต้องปิดหน้าสามีนักเรียนบอกกัน port
ก็เห็นหน้าสามีคุณแล้วเป็นมึง
จะมีขี้อายนะคะอ่าอ่ะคนต่างชาติเราก็ปิด
ไว้ก่อนขอโทษนะคะ
นักเรียนครูต้องปิดก่อนมั้ย
เก๋อันนี้เรียกว่างานอะไรนะคะงานศพค่ะ
งานศพก็คืออันนี้เป็นงานพี่ชายครูเดี๋ยว
เจ๊เสียชีวิตมาถึงยังไงถ้าคิดว่าพี่ชาย
เบื่อกูเอกพูดเอา
กูเองเวลาที่เราไปงานศพต้องพูดอะไรกับครู
เอ๋ไหมคะก็ขอแสดงความเสียใจ
เสียใจเสียใจถ้าเป็นงานแต่งงานก็ขอแสดง
ความยินดีนะคะ
แต่ว่างานศพเนี่ย
ใส่สีแดงได้ไหมครูต้อมหนูไม่ได้ค่าสีม่วง
ไม่ได้ค่ะ
สีดำ
ต้องได้ค่ะสีขาว
มีขาวก็ไม่ค่อยดีนะคะไม่ค่อยใส่ถ้าเธอไม่
ค่อยใส่แต่จริงๆแล้วหน้าใส่ได้อ๋อค่ะใส่
ได้อยู่ที่คนคนนี้คนเสียชีวิตเนี่ยค่ะคน
เสียชีวิตเนี้ยถ้าอย่างพี่ชายเอ๋เป็นพี่
เอ๋เป็นน้องน้องใส่สีขาวได้
หรือว่าคนที่มาอายุน้อยๆน่ะใส่เสื้อสีขาว
ได้ถ้าคนที่เสียชีวิตแก่แล้วก็เสียชีวิต
นะครับอายุสมุด 70 ปีพี่ไม่ถึง 70 นะคะ 70
ปีอย่างเงี้ยเสียชีวิตเราใส่สีขาวไปไม่
ใช่ครอบครัวก็ใส่สีขาวได้นะคะ
ไก่สีขาวแบบนี้ได้แต่ว่าว่าถ้า
ถ้าเขาเป็นคนอ่ะอายุมากกว่าต้องสระมีสีดำ
ต้องใส่สีดำ
อาจจะใส่ชุดแบบไทยแบบนี้เป็นชุดแบบนี้
แล้วแต่งงานข้างๆๆก็เป็นเสื้อ
เราไปงานกันก็เสื้อกระโปรง
ค่ะหรือกางเกงกูต้องใส่กางเกง
ใส่อันนี้เป็นไปงานศพนะฉันเมื่อกี้พูดถึง
งานแต่งงานว่าเองไปแล้วใส่มุกใช่ไหมใส่
มุกได้ไหมบอกว่าสร้อยมุกเนี่ยเขาบอกคน
เป็นน้ำตาน้อง
อ้าจะมาเป็นน้ำตาของหอยเวลางานแต่งงานน่ะ
ไม่อยากให้มีอะไรที่เป็นน้ำตาอ๋อ
เพราะว่าหอยมันเจ็บมันมีอะไรเข้าไปเจ็บ
แล้วคะแล้วก็เป็นมุก
คุณป้าเอ๋นะซีเรียสมากไม่ให้ใส่มุกคู๋นะ
เวลาแต่งงาน่จะใส่มุกใช่ไหมคะป้าน่ะไม่
ให้แล้วชุดแต่งงานกูเอ๋น่ะจริงๆมันมีอะไร
หนึ่งอย่างเป็นมุกปากโกรธ
เวดดิ้งสตูดิโอจัดมามีมุกคุณป้าโกรธทำไว้
ใจอย่างดีเย็นปีนี้ไม่เป็นไร
[เพลง]
คุณปรากฏให้หน่อยว่าทำไมมีมุกใจเย็นๆทุก
คนก็ได้บอกว่าโอ๊ยคิดว่าดีก็ดี
ใจเย็นใจเย็น
ค่ะผู้เก๋ใส่แล้วสวยด้วยพระเอกไม่มีปัญหา
กับหมูแต่ว่าผู้ใหญ่ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบได้เอ๋
โอเคใส่อะไรก็ได้อ่า
ใส่สีใส่สีขาวมาโอเคใส่เสื้อยืดกางขาสั้น
โอเคโอเค
อะไรก็ได้นักเรียนถามโค๊ะใส่อะไรดี
อะไรก็ได้
สีดำเนี่ยคุยขอเพราะว่าถ้าใส่สีดำเนี่ย
โอ้คุณป้าน่าจะร้องไห้เลยหนูกลับไปกลับไป
น้องมีหนึ่งคนใส่สูทสีดำอ๋อแล้วมีเนคไท
มันคุยสีขาวศูนย์
ศูนย์สีดำแล้วก็ข้างในสีขาวแล้วก็สีดำ
ยุโรปไงคุณต้อง
ยุโรปอ้ะเค้าใส่สีดำไปงานแต่งงาน
ญี่ปุ่นด้วยใส่กิมมะโนสีดำไปงานแต่งงาน
หนอ
เอ็งเคยไปงานแต่งงานในงานคนอื่นอ่ะไข่จีน
แต่งงานกับคนญี่ปุ่นคนไทยตีก็สีแดงทั้ง
หมดเลย
คนญี่ปุ่นไม่ชอบแบบเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยคุณแม่
คนญี่ปุ่นใส่สีดำคุณแม่ฝ่ายไทยจีนไม่ชอบ
ไม่ชอบ
ครูเอ๋ทำไมใส่สีดำ
กูเองต้องเบาะญี่ปุ่นเค้าเจอแต่ว่าดีมาก
เอาอันนี้ดีมากเป็นสีดำแล้วก็มีนก
สีทองสีเงิน
สวยต้องคุยคุยคุณแม่ผู้หญิงผู้ชายสบายใจ
โอเค
สบายใจ
วัฒนธรรมน่ะไม่เหมือนกันใช่ไหมกดต้องอ่า
ของคุณต้อมคิดถ้าเป็นครูต้องคิดว่าใส่มุก
เป็นงานแต่งงานได้
วายเพราะครูต้อมอ่ะไม่รู้เรื่องมีหอยร้อง
ห้างอ่ะหรอแล้วอื้อคุณแม่กูต้องโอเคไหม
อ่ะใส่คุณแม่โอเคนะคุณแม่มึงต้องคิดว่า
คุณแม่ไม่รู้เรื่องขอย
[เพลง]
โอ้โหเหี๊ยใส่อะไรก็ได้
เรามาดู
เครื่องประดับต่อไปซอยพร้อมอันนี้ใส่ไป
งานแต่งงานได้ใช่ไหมคะได้ค่ะถ้า
ชุดดำงานศพแล้วมีพลอยสีแดง
สีน้ำเงินก็ได้
ได้ๆค่ะ
ชุดนี้นะใส่ไปงานงานคนตาย
ได้ลายไม่ได้ค่ากูเอ๋
ห้ามนะฮะไม่
ควรอ่ะเราไม่ใช่บอกห้ามร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
ไม่ควรใส่นะคะไม่ควรใส่คือถ้าใส่คือถ้า
ใส่ติดตัวจริงๆก็ให้เป็นสีน้ำเงินเนาะค่ะ
สีน้ำเงินแบบเนี้ยแต่ถ้าหนูไม่เป็นเล่นซิ
ๆเล็กน้อยแบบครูเอกแบบนี้ได้ใช่ไหมเล็กๆ
แบบน่ามองไม่เห็นไม่เห็นค่ะเนี่ยได้ต้มหู
นิด
แต่ถ้ามาแบบคู่แบบนี้เลย
ใหญ่ๆไม่ควรค่ะ
กูต้องค่ะไปดับอันนี้ไม่ได้ใส่มุกในงาน
งานคนตายโอเคโอเคนี้แหลงได้ไหมไม่ได้ลึก
สีดำไม่ได้สีดำด้ายสีขาว
ได้แต่ต้องดูนะคะต้องเรียบร้อยสีขาวเรา
วับแวมๆเนี่ยไม่ได้กู a คะม็อบวะแวมคือ
อะไรวับๆแวมๆก็คืออะคุยว่าสีขาวชุดสีขาว
คะแล้วก็
[เพลง]
เซ็กซี่ Sexy อ๋อ
แบบเนี้ย
สีขาวแล้วก็เซ็กซี่พกแบมขอโป๊
แสดงบล็อกแบมเห็นนิดๆหน่อย
หนูไม่ได้ 100% เดียวข่าวก็ไม่ได้เงยเขา
ไม่ได้อย่างเงี้ย
ต้มก็เห็นไงกับกระโปรง
ทำไมได้นะคะๆต้องยาวแบบเนี้ยได้นะคะเรียบ
รอ
งานศพ
สีน้ำเงินได้ใช่ไหมคะง่ายค่ะขาวสีเทาได้
ไม่ค่ะแล้ว 4 ดูดวงได้ไหมคะสีม่วงใส่ได้
นะคะปกติไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคะปกติไม่ได้ค่ะปกติ
คือเก้าสิบเก้าสิบเก้าสิบกี่เปอร์เซ็นต์
ดี
95% ไหมคะ 15  98  99
98 ถึง 99 เปอร์เซ็นต์ไม่
ใส่สีม่วงไปงานคนตายหรืองานศพเราพูดงานศพ
นะคะได้ว่างานศพก็คือคนแต่
ไม่ใส่แล้วอีก 1 เปอร์เซ็นน่ะกูต้องอีก 1%
1% ใส่ได้ค่ะถ้าคนตายเขาอยากให้ใส่หื้อ
เขาชอบประหยัดที่สาทรเขาชอบและเขาพูดเอา
ไว้กับลูกๆว่ามางานศพเขาเขาให้ใส่สีม่วง
มีหรือมางานศพใส่สีชมพูเพราะว่าเขาชอบเรา
ก็เขาอาจจะอายุประมาณ
80  80 ถึง 100 ปี
ด้วยคะมีอายุนานๆเราก็นอนหลับไม่ตื่น
ค่ะใส่สีม่วงได้ภาพคนในครอบครัวบอกว่าใส่
ได้ใช่ไหมกูเอกเคยเห็นงานสีม่วงด้วยนะคุณ
ต้อง
คุยไปงานศพแล้วงานที่กูแอบไปอ้ะสีดำ
คนใส่สีดำแต่ว่างานใกล้ๆคุยทำไมผ้าสีม่วง
ทุกอย่างสีม่วงคนมางานก็มีสีม่วงบ้างสีสี
ดำบ้างป่า
อันนี้ที่วัดงานอะไรคะอ่ะหมอก็บอกว่าอ๋อ
งานศพเอ้ยทำไมสีม่วงเขาก็บอกว่าจริงๆสี
ม่วงใส่ได้นะถ้าไปหาขนาดมังกร
เมื่อก่อนเขาบอกถ้าคนที่เสียชีวิตแก่แล้ว
อ่ะแก่แล้วก็นานๆแล้วก็เป็นพิธี
พิธีสำคัญอะไรสักอย่างไม่รู้ก็สีม่วงเอก
โอเคก็เลยเข้าใจว่าสีม่วงใส่ได้แต่ไม่ใช่
ง่วงแบบ
สว่างเป็นมั่วมั่วๆดำๆมืดหมดเค็มเค็มๆๆ
ประมาณกระเป๋าคู๋นี่แหละอ๋อแบบนี้ค่ะ
อันนี้นิกูเอคะงานศพดาราสิ่งที่มึงไทย
เมื่อเดือนที่แล้ว
เขาให้ใส่สีชมพูงู
ทุกคนใส่สีชมพูสำหรับขาวกลับไปสวรรค์ใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะ
คนตายที่เป็นดาราเขาชอบสีชมพูมากก็
สีชมพูสีส้มอ่อนชอบมาทุกคนก็ไปให้เขามี
ความสุขจริงๆคุณเอกก็ไม่ชอบให้ใส่สีดำนะ
อีกเลยพูดกับคุณแม่บอกว่าถ้าเอ๋ตายขอให้
ทุกคนใส่สีที่ตัวเองชอบนะก็ไม่อยากเห็นคน
ร้องไห้อ๋อเมียกูเอ๋หาพูดว่าตายคนไทยคิด
ว่าไม่ดีๆคุณครูพูดบ่อยพอ
คิดว่าห้ามพูดว่าตายดีนะคะใช่คนไทยไว้ให้
พูดตายคนไทยให้พูดดีเองทำไมพูดไม่ได้นะ
ต้องพูดได้เอ๋บอกว่าอ้าต้องเตรียมถ้า
อนาคตมีรถชนมีอะไรต้อง 1  2  3  4  5
ต้องเตรียมเอาไว้ต้องต้องพูดโอเคอันนี้
อยู่ที่นี่อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้ต้องเตรียม
แต่คุณแม่ผู้เอกไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ไปบ่ต้องเข้าใจกูอาจจะได้สบายใจ
ถ้ากูเอกตายแล้วก็อีกไม่อยากคิดแม่คิด
อะไรคนนี้กินอะไรต้องบอกก่อนใช่ไหมคะแม่
บอกไม่เอาพูดเหมือนคุณน้องเลยเหมือนคน
ต้องต้องรอหมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่าหมด
เวลาแล้วนี่อ่ะค่ะงั้นคลิปนี้นักเรียนก็
รู้แล้วนะคะว่าถ้านักเรียนมาเมืองไทยไป
งานแต่งงานเสื้อผ้าสีอะไรที่ห้ามใส่นะคะ
ไปงานศพนะคะ
ใส่อะไรได้ต้องบอกว่าใส่อะไรได้มี 2 สีนะ
คะสีดำสีขาวสีเทาแบบกูต้มก็ได้สีน้ำเงิน
ถ้าไม่มีไม่มีสีดำจริงๆก็เป็นสีสีสี
น้ำเงินแบบเงินสีน้ำเงินแบบเนี้ยน้ำเงิน
มากๆถ้าไม่มีเสื้อผ้านะคะไม่มีแต่สีเทาสี
ขาวโอเคนะคะโอเคค่ะคลิปนี้เอกกับกูต้องไป
ก่อน
บ๊ายเปล่าก็ต้องบ๊ายบายขอบคุณนะคะครูเอ๋
คุณครูนักเรียนทุกคนบ๊ายบายน